the color is a striking red but its
beauty is more than skin deep the jvc gr
c7 enables you to record and sound on a
single convenient unit then play them
back immediately even when you're
nowhere near a television set like its
predecessor the GRC one maybe you
remember it from Back to the Future the
new JVC model owes its compact size to
special smaller vhs-c video cassettes
each can record up to 30 minutes and is
smaller than a deck of cards you can
play freeze frame and shuttle search
your videos and watch them through the
viewfinder on the half inch black and
white CRT display at almost four pounds
GV sees new video camera is more
portable than ever there's no more need
for a shoulder bracket to help support
its weight you can hold the GRC 7 steady
with just your hands to start shooting
you can even become the next John Hughes
send us pictures of your favorite retro
gadgets in the comments and please
subscribe to the wired Channel